Bonjour à tous ! Vous allez regarder les 3 premiers épisodes du dessin animé : Roger et ses humains.
Tirés de la meilleure bande dessinée du monde,
que j'ai écrite.
Bah ma BD Roger et ses humains, le tome 2 vient de sortir.
Je vous le conseille.
Ha ha! Des barres, c'est super !
Vous avez peut-être déjà vu le 3ème épisode puisqu'il à été diffusé sur ma chaîne
Donc, en tout cas, je vous souhaite un bon visionnage !
C'est parti !
*Générique*
♫~Roger
et ses humains~♫
*Bruit de chasse d'eau*
*Bâillement*
*Bruit de robot*
Hugo: "Mm ?"
"Bah, qu'est-ce que c'est ça ?"
"Qu'est ce ... Qu'est ce que ça fout là ce truc ?"
"UNE SURPRISE POUR MON ANNIVERSAIRE !?"
Ahh, c'est trop génial !
*Bruits de robots qui s’intensifient*
Hugo :Mm ?
AAAAA H !
"Aïe ..."
"AAAAHHH !  J'AI MAAAAAAL !"
*TRANSITION ROGER*
Hugo: "Uuuugh..."
Roger: "Bonjour!"
Hugo: "Bonjour ?! Tu te fouterais pas un peu de ma gueule?! Tu me frappes et tu me dis Bonjour !?!"
Roger: "J'ai fait une erreur d'évaluation."
"Je pensais que tu étais dangereux."
Hugo: "Moi dangeureux ?! Nan mais t'es pas b-"
"D-dangereux ?"
"Ah ouais? C'est la première fois qu'on me dit que ch'uis dangereux... Ha ha ha!"
Roger: "En réalité, ton taux de dangerosité  est de 0,0000..."
Hugo: "Ça va ,ça va, j'ai compris." Roger: (En arrière-plan) "00000..."
Roger: "...001."
Hugo: "Ouais t'aurais pu dire 0 tout court, quoi!"
Roger: "Non, ton taux de dangerosité est de 0,000..."
- Ahhh! Tais-toi !
*TRANSITION ROGER*
- Et donc comme ça c'est fou, hein ?  T'es...
T'es mon cadeau d'anniversaire
- Je ne sais pas
- Ouais.... T'es de quelle marque ?
- T.. T'as un nom ?
- Je ne sais pas
- Ouais remarque, vu ta gueule t'as pas besoin de nom
J'vais t'appeler "le robot" !
Ça sera carrément plus simple
Robot: Comme tu voudras, humain
Humain: Non robot, moi c'est Hugo
Robot: Très bien, humain
Hugo: Grrrr.. Bon, j'ai compris
J'vais te donner un prénom!
J'vais t'appeler... euh...
Roger !
Roger: Bonne idée,  humain !
Hugo : MAIS ARRÊTE DE M'APPELER COMME ÇA !!!
*Marmonne en lisant la notice*
Hugo: Oh! Sur la notice, c'est dit que t'es pas capable de mentir. C'est vrai ?
Roger: Exactement
Cette fonction n'a pas été implémentée dans mon système
*bruit de clé*
- Non mais cette journée mais j'en ai marre, je suis la seule femme qui doit s'occuper de toute la boîte !
Hugo: Ah...ça c'est Florence
Florence: Bah… C'est quoi ce robot ?
Hugo: Florence, c'est ton cadeau pour mon anniversaire !
Florence: Ton…anniversaire…
Hah ha ha... Oui !
Hugo: T'aurais pas oublié mon anniversaire quand même ?
Florence: Roh bah non !  Non, pas du tout !
Roger: C'est donc ça le mensonge?
J'aimerais pouvoir faire pareil
**Florence: Il peut pas fermer sa gueule, c'lui-là ?**
*TRANSITION ROGER*
Hugo: Et si c'est pas toi qui me l'a offert, ça vient de qui ?
Florence: Hmm...
Ah je sais ! Ça doit être un cadeau qu'on t'envoie quand tu cumules des points cher Carrouf
Ou un truc comme ça
Roger: Un vulgaire cadeau…
C'est donc toute l'estime que vous avez pour moi ?
Saviez-vous que j'ai un système atomique, que je peux faire exploser pour vous éliminer ?
*Florence rit*
Il est programmé pour faire des blagues ou …?
Hugo: Ah je sais pas !
En tout cas, il peut pas mentir
C'est marqué sur la notice, chaud le truc !
Roger: Explosion dans 3...
*Florence et Hugo crient et fuient*
...2...1...
*TRANSITION ROGER*
Florence: Bon, on va t'installer un... un bon lit et tout confortable, ok ?
Roger: Ce n'est pas nécessaire, j'ai seulement besoin d'une prise murale
Hugo: Une prise ? T'es comme un téléphone portable en fait !
Roger: Je suis...
*Hugo rit*
Roger: ...un téléphone portable ?
Hugo: HA HA !!  Gros schlag !!  HA HA !!
Roger: Explosion dans 3...
Hugo: Nan nan nan!! Je retire ce que j'ai dit !!
T'es beau, t'es génial ! T'es mieux qu'un mixeur !
Tiens mon p'tit loulou !
T'as une prise juste là, rien que pour toi !
Florence: Bonne nuit !
Hugo: Et donc Roger, tu sers à quoi, exactement ?
Roger: Et toi Hugo, tu sers à quoi, exactement ?
Hugo: Mais putain, t'es obligé d'être aussi désagréable…
Hé... Tu sais faire à manger ?
Roger: Non, mais je peux apprendre
Florence: Quoi ? Tu veux dire que...
...que j'aurai plus jamais à faire la cuisine !?
YEEEEEES !!!!!!
À MOI LA LIBERTÉ !!
C'EST LA FIN DU PATRIARCHAT !
*Florence devient folle*
Hugo: C'est rien, me regarde pas comme ça
C'est normal, c'est la pression de la société
*TRANSITION ROGER*
Roger: Voilà
Avec une recette trouvée sur Internet
J'ai préparé un gâteau pour ton anniversaire
Florence: Il est chanmé ce robot !
*mange*
Hmm! Non mais attend il est super bon !
Roger: Le plus dur était de trouver
les feuilles de cannabis
Florence: Hm- ?!
*Sous LSD*
Hugo: Ton visage il tourne
Florence: Je le kiff trop ce robot ! *bisous
Hugo : C'est doux la table !
Vous voulez pas on se caresse tous les genoux ?
*TRANSITION ROGER*
Florence: Aaargh… ma tête !
Hugo: La vache... !  Ouf !
Roger: Désolé pour le gâteau tout à l'heure
J'ai fais une omelette pour me faire pardonner
Florence: Ooh... Y'a pas de cannabis, j'espère ?
Roger: Non
Hugo: Cool, j'ai trop la dalle !
*mange*
Roger: Et j'ai trouvé moi même les champignons
Florence: HMM?! Les champignons ?!?
*Retour mode LSD*
Hugo: Chanmé !
Florence: Je kiff trop ce robot !
Hugo: Franchement...
J'ai envie de tous vous lécher l'oreille à tous
*slurp*
Mais comme un copain !
Pas comme un amoureux, tu vois ?
Plus on fait du camping, on fait du poney
Qui fait le poney ?
Celui qui a le plus de ch'veux
Ça s'ra pas Roger !
Roger : Heureux que mon plat vous plaise
Je vais en donner aux enfants du quartier
Merci d'avoir regardé !
Je ne peux que vous conseiller le tome 2 de ma BD qui vient de sortir
Et moi, j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à travailler sur le dessin animé,  puisque je fais la voix de Roger notamment
La suite des épisodes est prévue pour l'année prochaine
Et moi, je vous dis à très vite.
Abonne-toi... S'il te plait.
** Toujours être poli **
*musique de fin*